Welcome back to CS215.
This the beginning of Unit 6, which is going to cover the hardness of network problems.
All right, I made another magic trick and I'm going to show it to you now.
So this is a map of a country that used to be part of the old Soviet Union called Tetristan
and it consist of 8 counties, which I've labeled A, B, C, D, E, F, G and H.
And what I'd like you to do is color the map each one with one of three colors
so that no two counties that are touching show the same color
and then I want you to number those colors--0, 1 and 2,
and then depending on which numbers you assigned to each colors
and which colors you assigned to each counties, I want you to calculate the color of county D
plus the color of county F plus the color of county C times the color of county G
minus the color of county A plus the color of county H.
I want you to work out what that number is and then write it in this block,
but before you write it let me see if I can guess what it's going to be.
Yes--yes, I have a very good guess as to what it's going to be, but you write it in
and let me make sure I'm right.